Rusia asegura estar respetando su
promesa el Ministerio de defensa del
kremlin señaló que las tropas honrarán
el cese el fuego unilateral decretado
por la navidad ortodoxa sin embargo
admitieron haber atacado las posiciones
ucranianas en respuesta a la
contraofensiva de kiev a pesar del
bombardeo de artillería de las fuerzas
ucranianas en áreas civiles y posiciones
rusas un grupo de nuestras tropas
seguirán manteniendo el alto el fuego
declarado hasta la medianoche quien
rechazó la oferta del alto del fuego de
Moscú y junto con el pentágono al
acusado a las tropas rusas De no
respetar su alto el fuego unilateral y
utilizarlo como una estrategia de guerra
para ganar terreno el peligro de ataques
aéreos y con misiles permanece en toda
Ucrania los principales esfuerzos del
enemigo se centran en intentar capturar
completamente la región de donietsk
dentro de la frontera administrativa
llevó a cabo operaciones ofensivas en la
dirección de bahamut Mientras tanto en
bakuth sus habitantes denunciaron que
los ataques no han cesado durante la
supuesta rusa
creo que nos están engañando es bastante
obvio si alguien hace una promesa debe
cumplirla
el alto el fuego sabes cómo funciona
cuando Putin dice que hay un alto el
fuego en realidad es al revés Ellos nos
bombardearon mucho ayer durante la noche
fue más o menos tranquilo así suele ser
un día hay bombardeos el otro día es más
tranquilo
la iglesia ortodoxa celebra la Navidad
el 7 de enero Aunque la principal
iglesia ortodoxa de Ucrania ha rechazado
la autoridad de Moscú y muchos creyentes
han cambiado su calendario para celebrar
la Navidad el 25 de diciembre como en